volcanic eruptions like this may look
mesmerizing
and sometimes attract flocks of tourists
but they're also dangerous events that
impact human activities displace people
and cost lives
the prediction is that we will lose some
50 of our gdp
as a result of the volcanic eruption
take this volcano on the caribbean
island of saint vincent
no deaths were reported but many people
had to evacuate and ash blanketed entire
neighborhoods
or this icelandic volcano that erupted
in 2010 paralyzing air traffic and
costing nearly five billion dollars to
global gdp
so far tools like seismicity monitors
have allowed volcanologists to forecast
unrest days or weeks in advance
but now nasa scientists say they can
help forecast eruptions months or even
years ahead of time
using satellite imagery and monitoring
changes in ground temperature we wanted
to
to understand to what extent the heat
released by volcanoes
can be used to detect when volcanoes
start to reactivate
there are many impacts of volcanic
eruptions
and our goal is to minimize those
impacts as
much as possible so here's how it works
and how scientists say we could benefit
from this new research
an early sign of a volcanic eruption is
heat as the magma underground rises
bringing warm gases to the surface
we see that these heat emissions start
to appear for several
months to years before eruption and we
observe these signals prior to the
changes that we observe with other types
of signals the problem is that these
heat emissions can be hard to monitor on
the ground
so jarona and his team turn to the sky
nasa satellites have already been
recording years of information
on thermal activity in fact none of
these satellites
have been designed specifically to
explore volcanoes
we can still use that information for
monitoring volcanic eruptions
after looking at two decades of radiant
heat data for several volcanoes
the researchers found a pattern in the
years leading up to an eruption
temperatures increased over much of each
volcano before dropping again
after the eruption we are detecting the
early reactivation of the volcano
which is crucial to improve the
monitoring efforts
[Music]
but before this technology can be fully
deployed in the real world
scientists will have to process much
more data hopefully in a few years we
can have a better understanding of these
signals better understanding of
volcanoes
and we can provide accurate forecasts
with about 1 500 active volcanoes on
earth
and troves of satellite data for each
one of them the nasa team is seeking
help from algorithms and other
researchers around the world
this is another tool in our in our
toolbox that's mike poland
he's a geophysicist for the us
geological survey
he says that these satellite images will
have to be used in tandem with other
traditional methods if you're building a
house you don't just show up with a
screwdriver you've got
a screwdriver a hammer a saw we need a
diverse tool kit so that we can
recognize
all the different types of signs that
volcanoes might be
giving us seismometers gas sensors and
radar sensors
are some of the tools that
volcanologists will continue to use
giving communities more time to prepare
could make the difference between saving
livelihoods or not
in saint vincent the local observatory
noticed signs of unrest weeks in advance
and officials were ready to evacuate 20
000 residents before the volcano erupted
helping to avoid casualties and greater
damage but with even more warning
officials say they may have been able to
avoid damage such as water contamination
for example
when the massive eruption that took
place it compromised
our entire water supply all of our
reservoirs
were contaminated with ash we were
without water for a couple days
and perhaps going forward we can look at
maybe putting in
you know tanks where persons can store
water
and properly you know we have to look at
a greater mitigation
and where natural disasters are
concerned and in the case of that
icelandic volcano
scientists say that more warning would
have given the aviation industry more
time to adapt and find alternative
routes it's important for caster options
because we can
reduce the impact at a local scale but
also at a global
scale if we are talking about much
larger eruptions